it is unusual for a game to launch with
almost no fanfare and then capture the
attention of so many different people in
the space of a month but rocket League
did just that in July of 2015 when it
accumulated more than five million
downloads across playstation 4 and pc it
was a soccer ball and a car that
resonated with us the most July wasn't
thin on good games earlier in the month
episode 5 of Telltale's Game of Thrones
series showed us once again that
telltale is capable of crafting haunting
emotional stories its tumultuous events
culminated with a heart-wrenching ending
that moved us to talk at length about
our choices and what's still to come in
the final episode n + + on the other
hand proved that the formula first
explored by the 2004 flash game and is
still excellent even in 2015 and yet we
kept coming back to rocket League every
game is set up the same way the same
layout of the field the same locations
of burst pads even the same car starts
but rocket League has still yet to lose
its allure whether we're playing quick
games during our lunch break or massive
marathons on the weekends rocket League
has proven to be a deep rewarding and
pure competitive experience for the way
it manages to be one of the best sports
games in recent years and keeps matches
intense and exciting while also bound by
a set of well-defined physics and
gameplay rules rocket league is
gamespot's game of the month for July
2015